assuming we get to the moon in one piece
which is already an incredibly difficult
task on its own you'll then have to
worry about establishing a base experts
suggest that we live on the moon's South
Pole as it gets the most consistent
amount of sunlight there are also
massive fields of ice that we'll be able
to harvest luckily you'll have robots to
help you establish a base there are many
different ways they'll be able to help
one includes using Moon soil to
construct bricks and configuring them in
a dome like fashion sort of like a moon
glue this would make traveling to the
Moon a lot cheaper as we wouldn't have
to bring everything from Earth to make
our base but don't expect this base to
be glamorous it'll most likely be
several meters underground to protect
you from the sun's radiation